For ADSP the podcast, it's our tradition. We're on tradition You're not gonna appreciate my fiddler solo Welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 56 recorded on December 20th 2021 My name is Connor and today with my co-host bryce we have our adsp holiday special casual christmas chat episode merry christmas are you recording yeah you can't say merry christmas though man happy holidays i gotta i gotta i got a question for for all for all of you who celebrate Christmas. Okay, what's up?
欢迎来到 ADSP 播客，这是我们的传统。我们有传统你不会欣赏我的提琴独奏欢迎来到 ADSP 播客第 56 期于 2021 年 12 月 20 日录制我的名字是康纳今天我的联合主持人布莱斯也在，我们有我们的 adsp 节日特别版休闲圣诞聊天节目圣诞快乐你在录音吗？对，但你不能说圣诞快乐，伙计。节日快乐我有个，我有个，我有个问题，问，问所有，所有庆祝圣诞节的人。好吧，怎么了？
Wait, wait, before that question. Here we go. Here we go. The black cherry buble in celebration of the holidays. Here we go. Oh, that is crisp, let me tell you. Let me tell you. Dear listener, please let us know if you'd like that
等等，等等，在那个问题之前。我们开始吧。我们开始吧。黑樱桃苏打水，为了庆祝节日。我们开始吧。哦，那个真的很爽脆，我跟你讲。我跟你讲。亲爱的听众，请告诉我们你是否希望
to stop i would like that to stop but nope no no no no no list dear listener you go right ahead and let us know if you'd like that to stop and i will go right ahead and ignore all of the said feedback asking me to stop it's like it's a part of it's a part of the podcast lore now we can't get rid of it absolutely absolutely not i'm not just gonna stop so maybe we'll upgrade from bubblies to something one day but um i got a question for all of you people who celebrate christmas which i do not because i'm jewish although as a kid i did until uh until my so i i had christmas as a kid I did until my, so I had Christmas as a kid because my dad was Christian. Well, pretty loose use of the word Christian here. But anyways, he did Christmas when he was a kid.
停下来我希望那个停下来，但是不，不，不，不，不，不，亲爱的听众，你尽管去告诉我们你是否希望那个停下来，而我会直接忽略所有那些要求我停下来的反馈这就像是，这已经是播客传说的一部分了，我们现在无法摆脱它绝对，绝对不行我不会就这么停下来所以也许有一天我们会从苏打水升级到别的什么东西，但是嗯，我有一个问题要问你们所有庆祝圣诞节的人，而我不庆祝，因为我是犹太人，虽然作为一个孩子我曾经庆祝过，直到，直到我的，所以我小时候过过圣诞节。我确实过过，直到我的，所以我小时候过过圣诞节，因为我爸爸是基督徒。好吧，这里对“基督徒”这个词的使用相当随意。但无论如何，他小时候过过圣诞节。
So when I was a very young kid, we did both Christmas and Hanukkah. Including when my mother and I lived at my grandparents' house when she took a few years off just to, you know, be a stay-at-home mom with me because she wanted a break from being a lawyer. And my grandparents were, like, much more Jewish than we were. And so my mother had to, like, sneak a Christmas tree into the house so that I could continue having Christmas. I remember one time, like, coming home and she and she like led me to my bedroom and there were lights coming from my bedroom and I'm like, what's going on? There was a little Christmas tree in my bedroom. But then she married my stepdad, very nice Jewish man. And then
所以当我还是个很小的孩子时，我们既过圣诞节又过光明节。包括我和妈妈住在外公外婆家的时候，当时她辞职几年，只是为了，你知道的，做我的全职妈妈，因为她想从律师的工作中休息一下。而我的外公外婆比我们犹太得多。所以我的妈妈不得不，像，偷偷把一棵圣诞树带进屋里，这样我才能继续过圣诞节。我记得有一次，像是，回家后她，她领着我进我的卧室，从我的卧室里传出灯光，我在想，怎么回事？我的卧室里有一棵小圣诞树。但后来她嫁给了我的继父，一个非常好的犹太男人。然后
suddenly Christmas went away from me. So there was a period of time where I blamed my stepfather for taking Christmas away from me. Now, hopefully none of my family is listening to this because my recollection might not be entirely accurate. I mean, it does sound like it was his fault. That's not an unreasonable thing for you to have done. Him and I did not get along when we first met. I was like 10 at the time, and he told my mom, like, I'm really good with kids. And I was like a pretty sensitive child in all the wrong ways. And the first time he meets me, he picks me up and hangs me upside down holding me by my ankles and i was
突然之间，圣诞节从我的生活中消失了。所以有一段时间我怪我继父把圣诞节从我身边夺走了。现在，希望我的家人没有在听这个，因为我的记忆可能不是完全准确。我是说，听起来确实是他的错。你这样做并不是不合理的。我和他刚见面时处得不好。我当时大概10岁，他跟我妈说，我对小孩挺有一套。而我在所有错误的地方都是个相当敏感的孩子。他见到我的第一下，把我抱起来倒挂着，抓着我的脚踝，我当时
like what the f**k go away like this is not amusing for me anyways do you want do you want me to censor that those swear words or want to leave this in christmas holiday special the holiday special probably censor it especially since i suppose there's now some probability that my family will be listening to this one. All right. Anyways, anyways. What's the question that you have for the Christmas people? Is Christmas actually fun? Because it seems like all of you just like spend two months being miserable and stressing out about getting everybody gifts and then
就想，去他的，走开，这对我一点都不好笑。不管怎样，你想，你想让我把那些脏话消音还是保留在圣诞节日特别节目里？节日特别节目可能还是消音吧，尤其是考虑到我猜现在我的家人听到这个的可能性有所增加。好吧。不管怎样，不管怎样。你对圣诞节的人有什么问题？圣诞节真的好玩吗？因为在你们所有人看来，好像就是花两个月时间过得很痛苦，为给每个人买礼物而压力山大，然后
stressing out about holiday drama. And then I keep hearing these things about these crazy gift exchange things where everybody buys a gift, but then you get to swap with other people's gifts if you don't like your gift. And that just sounds like a really great way to start a family feud. It just seems like a whole bunch of drama. And I don't know, maybe it's just my family, but like the holidays are like not a, it's a very calm, chill time, except Thanksgiving. Thanksgiving is like, you know, its own whole drama. And then we have this whole crazy Passover thing, but like, it just doesn't seem like Christmas is really that fun for anybody other than like kids. Like, it seems like it's fun if you're like a kid.
又为节日戏剧性事件而压力山大。然后我一直听到关于这些疯狂的礼物交换的事情，每个人都买一件礼物，但如果你不喜欢你的礼物，你就可以跟别人的礼物互换。这听起来真是一个引发家庭不和的绝佳方式。这看起来只是一堆抓马。而且我不知道，也许只是我的家庭吧，但是节日并不是一个，这是一个非常平静、放松的时期，感恩节除外。感恩节就像是，你知道的，它有它自己的一整套抓马。然后我们有这个疯狂的逾越节活动，但是，它就是让人觉得圣诞节对除了小孩子以外的任何人来说都不是那么好玩。你看，如果你是个小孩子，它似乎挺好玩的。
But then when you're an adult, it's just like, oh, my God, I got to go buy like gifts for like 40 family members. So I shall be the representative for all Christmas people across the globe. They voted and elected me their Christmas leader. You're not you're not wrong. I believe a Christmas leader is called a Santa Claus. Do I have that correctly? Sure. I'll be Santa.
但当你成了成年人，就变成了，哦，天哪，我得去给大概40个家庭成员买礼物。所以我将作为全球所有过圣诞节的人的代表。他们投票选举我为他们的圣诞领袖。你没有，你没有说错。我想圣诞领袖被称为圣诞老人。我没说错吧？当然。我来当圣诞老人。
Ho, ho, ho. This episode has very quickly gone off the rails. I was just thinking that. I was just thinking, we're two minutes in. How are we so far from where we should be what do you mean so this is we have our tradition which started last year so it's not really it's becoming your tradition this year seeing as we're repeating it it's the holiday special i i already told you i'm jewish it's not tradition unless my people have been doing it for 6,000 years. So in 6,000 years, it'll be tradition.
吼，吼，吼。这期节目很快就彻底失控了。我刚才就在想这个。我刚刚在想，才过去两分钟。我们怎么离正题十万八千里了？你什么意思？所以这是，我们有去年开始的传统，所以其实不算，今年它正在变成你的传统，鉴是我们在重复它，这是节日特别节目我，我刚才就告诉你了我是犹太人除非我族人已经做了6000年，否则这就不算传统。所以在6000年后，它才会成为传统。
For ADSP, the podcast, it's our tradition. We're on tradition. You're not going to appreciate my fiddler solo? No, I will cut in a clip from Fiddler on the Roof. Perfect. And how do we keep our balance? That I can tell you in one word. Tradition. Perfect! And how do we keep our balance? That I can tell you in one word.
对于 ADSP 播客来说，这是我们的传统。我们在遵循传统。你难道不欣赏我的提琴独奏吗？不，我会剪入一段《屋顶上的提琴手》的片段。完美。我们如何保持平衡？这个我可以用一个词来回答。传统。完美！我们如何保持平衡？这个我可以用一个词来回答。
Tradition! Tradition! Tradition! Tradition! Tradition! Tradition! Tradition! Tradition!
传统！传统！传统！传统！传统！传统！传统！传统！
Tradition! Tradition! Tradition! Tradition! Tradition! So that you didn't think I got that reference, but I was raised by a mother who very much loved musicals. So I've seen all the musicals oh my god well you have to take your mother to new york and i guess you could probably come too but your mom and i need to go to some musicals together you can you can come too she's been um before and yeah she's seen some broadway and off-broadway stuff um but yes getting away let's answer the Christmas question. You're not wrong. So like several years ago now, I remember there being some family drama in just that like a lot of – so I have three sisters.
传统！传统！传统！传统！传统！这样你就不会以为我没听懂那个梗了，我是被一个非常热爱音乐剧的母亲抚养长大的。所以我看所有的音乐剧哦，天哪，好吧，你得带你妈妈去纽约，我想你大概也可以一起来，但你妈妈和我需要一起去看一些音乐剧你也可以，你也可以一起来她以前去，嗯，去过，而且，是的，她看过一些百老汇和外百老汇的演出，嗯，但是是的，言归正传，我们来回答关于圣诞节的问题。你没说错。所以就像现在好几年前，我记得当时有一些家庭抓马，就是有很多——所以我三个姐姐。
There's four kids in the family. And I think we were all working. And there was just like everyone's trying to buy gifts for parents plus three other people plus significant others, blah, blah, blah. And long story short, we came up with the rule that we just weren't going to do gifts anymore. If we were going to do gifts, it was going to be one of the things that you referred to as gift swapping. It's typically referred to as a white elephant gift exchange, which I will explain in a second. What do elephants have to do with this? I don't know the answer to that question.
家里有四个孩子。我想我们当时都在工作。然后就是每个人都试图给父母买礼物，再加上其他三个人，再加上另一半，巴拉巴拉巴拉。长话短说，我们想出了一个规矩，就是我们再也不送礼物了。如果我们要送礼物，那也得是你们所说的礼物互换的形式。这通常被称为白象礼物交换，我一会儿会解释。大象跟这个有什么关系？我不知道这个问题的答案。
I could look it up right now, but you know what? We will leave it to the listener. Never mind. Bryce is looking it up. Keep going. Keep going. And so, and yeah, I am very...
我现在可以查一下，但你知道吗？我们留给听众去查吧。没关系。布莱斯正在查。继续。继续。所以，是的，我非常……
Why is there no etymology section on this Wikipediaikipedia page for white elephant gifts exchange yes um i'm sure there's a section but uh i'm working on it i'm working on it you keep going but yeah it's um i'm a very anti-consumerist anti-capitalist kind of person what you say as you sit here with your like high end microphone dressed in your fancy
为什么维基百科上关于白象礼物交换没有词源部分？是的，嗯，我相信肯定有一个部分，但是，嗯，我在查，我在查，你继续，但，是的，它，嗯，我是那种非常反消费主义、反资本主义的人。你一边坐在那里，穿着你那高端麦克风，打扮得像个
like lululemon designer workout clothes first of all that is entirely false you capitalist scum we're going to get into this right now we're going off the rails we're get into this right now we're going off the rails we're already off the rails and we're gonna go off the rails even more first of all i'm wearing a free t-shirt that i got from running the 30k saratoga trail run
lululemon 设计师运动服饰，你一边这么说首先，完全没有这回事，你这个资本主义败类。我们现在就要谈这个了，我们彻底失控了，我们现在就要谈这个了，我们彻底失控了，我们已经失控了，我们要更进一步地失控。首先，我穿着一件免费的 T 恤，那是我跑 30 公里萨拉托加越野跑时拿到的，
um when i was in silicon valley so this t-shirt was free it's not it's not some luxury lululemon i am wearing lululemon shorts uh but that's just because that's what that's what you got to do and yeah i have a lot of like tech stuff keyboards computer you realize that that for the price that you paid for those shorts you could feed like a small village that's i mean they are more expensive shorts but they also like i have probably i probably have like three or four of the abc sort of dress shorts from lululemon and they each last like four to five years so like they're really high quality clothes how are you going through them in four to five years it's like i'm making fun of connor for this but literally my entire wardrobe is from the little woman like all of the clothing that i buy with the exception of tech shirts
嗯，当时我在硅谷。所以这件 T 恤是免费的。它不是，它不是什么奢侈的 lululemon。我穿着 lululemon 的短裤，但那只是因为那是，那是你必须要穿的。而且，是的，我有许多科技产品，键盘，电脑。你意识到，你买那些短裤的钱足够养活一个小村庄了？我的意思是，它们的的确确是比较贵的短裤，但它们也，我有，我大概有三四条 lululemon 的 abc 正装短裤，它们每条能穿四五年左右。所以，它们真的是高质量的衣服。你怎么能把它们穿得四五年就报废的？就像我在拿康纳开玩笑，但实际上我的整个衣柜都是 lululemon 的，除了科技面料 T 恤，
are from the little woman um but like how like they last like longer than four or five years for me i mean if you religiously only wear those you can burn through them like and that's the thing is i i do religiously only wear those. I just take better care of them than you. Now, when you wash them, do you wash them in a delicate load? No. There's the problem. There's the problem.
我买的所有衣服都是 lululemon 的。嗯，但是怎么，它们对我来说能穿超过四五年。我是说，如果你死守着只穿那些，你当然会把它们穿坏，而且问题是，我确实死守着只穿那些。我只是比你更爱护它们。那么，当你洗它们的时候，你会用轻柔洗涤模式吗？不会。问题就在这。问题就在这。
I wash them in a delicate load and then I air dry them. I do not put them in the dryer. I air dry them as well. But when it comes to washing, just there's no separate loads. Just everything goes in and we just put it on sport. You monster. You monster. What are you doing to your fancy microfiber whatever?
我用轻柔洗涤模式洗，然后风干。我不会把它们放进烘干机。我也风干它们。但是说到洗涤，根本没有什么分批洗。什么都扔进去，然后我们直接开运动模式。你这个怪物。你这个怪物。你在对你那些昂贵的超细纤维什么的做什么？
Anyways, anyways, the point is I live very minimalistically. If you've seen my plate, you've commented on how I have absolutely nothing on my walls. The only piece of furniture that I bought was my mattress. Everything else is like... His apartment looks like a place that you would get murdered. Yeah, it does a tiny bit. Whereas my apartment, my apartment is very, very swanky. Like, my taste in furniture... What is it?
不管怎样，不管怎样，重点是我过着极简主义的生活。如果你看过我的盘子，你就会评论说我的墙上绝对空无一物。我买的唯一一件家具就是我的床垫。其他的一切都是……他的公寓看起来像个会发生谋杀案的地方。是的，确实有点像。而我的公寓，我的公寓非常非常时髦。比如，我对家具的品味……是什么？
You like mahogany? No, not walnut. is that the wood you like yes yes the point being Bryce furnishes his place with walnut furniture I furnish my place with stuff that I got for free from people that were leaving town and i am i'm not like a minimalist by name but i definitely i and that's the thing i don't count technology products like keyboards laptops hardware uh wireless headphones i don't i don't count that because like that's my that's my work that's like my life but like outside of that stuff there are like four things that i consider of like i own like i own a vitamix that's a key part of my life wait what a what a vitamix it's a what do you take a take a guess
你喜欢红木？不，不是胡桃木。那是你喜欢的木头吗？是的，是的，重点是布莱斯用胡桃木家具来布置他的住所。我用从搬走的人那里免费得来的东西来布置我的住所，而且我，我虽然不是名义上的极简主义者，但我绝对，而且就是这样，我不把科技产品算在内，比如键盘、笔记本电脑、硬件、无线耳机，我不把那些算进去，因为那是我的工作，那是我的生活。但除此之外，有四样东西我认作是我的所有物，比如我有一个 Vitamix，那是我的生活中的关键部分。等等，什么？Vitamix 是什么？它是个什么，你猜猜
what do you think that is i have no clue that's why i asked you it's A container for your vitamins? No. It is a blender with 2.2 horsepower. My blender is better. What brand is your blender? Blendtec? No. Is it? Yes, it is Blendtec.
你觉得那是什么？我毫无头绪，这就是我问你的原因它是装维生素的容器吗？不是。它是一个拥有 2.2 马力的搅拌机。我的搅拌机比它好。你的搅拌机是什么牌子的？Blendtec？不是。是吗？是的，是 Blendtec。
I mean, arguably Vitamix is the gold standard. Connor, you will come over to my place someday. Bryce, I might cut this. Well, you know what? Screw it. I'll leave it in. Because this is going to go against me saying that I'm a minimalist and an anti-consumerist. I think mine could physically beat up yours. Figure out how much horsepower yours has. Mine's got 2.2 horsepower.
我的意思是，可以说 Vitamix 是行业金标准。康纳，你总有一天会来我家的。布莱斯，我可能会把这段剪掉。好吧，你知道吗？去他的。我留着它。因为这会跟我之前说的我是个极简主义者和反消费主义者相矛盾。我觉得我的马力物理上能打赢你的。查查看你的有多少马力。我的有 2.2 马力。
It's got more horsepowers. This holiday special is such a mess. I'm looking up my mom. Looking up things. While Bryce is looking up stuff, the point is I'm sort of against gifts for family. Christmas time for me is about just spending time with friends and family. And I think that is honestly the case for a lot of folks that celebrate Christmas. It does not list its horsepower. You know what?
它有更多马力。这个节日特别节目真是太乱了。我在查我妈。在查东西。在布莱斯查东西的时候，重点是我有点反对给家人送礼。对我来说，圣诞节就是和朋友家人共度时光。老实说，对于许多庆祝圣诞节的人来说也是如此。它没有列出马力。你知道吗？
Probably it's because it's ashamed of how little horsepower it has compared to Vitamix's. I think that is highly unlikely. I'll keep going. I'll keep going. You keep doing your thing. I'll stop. I'll stop. I'll stop.
可能是因为它觉得自己的马力跟 Vitamix 比起来太少，所以不好意思吧。我觉得这不太可能。我继续说。我继续说。你忙你的。我停。我停。我停。
It has a 1200 watt motor. Yeah. If you got to measure it in like watts, that sounds pretty disappointing. I think you are wrong. But all right. All right. Let's move on. Let's move on. Anyways. But, but. All right. All right. Let's move on. Let's move on.
它有 1200 瓦的电机。对。如果你得用瓦特来衡量，听起来挺让人失望的。我觉得你错了。不过好吧。好吧。我们继续。我们继续。不管怎样。但是，但是。好吧。好吧。我们继续。我们继续。
Anyways. So, yeah, I think that there are buying gifts for a bunch of people can be stressful. And the solution is to figure out a way not to have to buy gifts. And to explain White Elephant. Oh, I did. I did find. I did find why it's called White Elephant. I do not know if this is accurate, but apparently the origin of the term stems back to the kingdom of Siam, modern-day Thailand, where the Siamese king, Siam, I don't know how to pronounce that, would gift an actual white elephant to those who displeased him.
不管怎样。所以，是的，我觉得，给一大群人买礼物可能会很有压力。而解决办法就是想办法不用买礼物。至于解释白象规则。哦，我找到了。我找到了为什么它被称为白象。我不知道这是否准确，但这个术语的起源显然可以追溯到暹罗王国，即当代的泰国，暹罗国王，暹罗，我不知道怎么发音，会把一头真正的白象送给那些惹恼他的人。
Interesting. Okay. Good to know. The way it works is there's a different variance of the game. The one that typically my family does is you have whatever, 10 people, 10 gifts. They're all wrapped. The person goes first, picks a gift, opens it up. And then the second person has a choice.
有意思。好吧。知道了。它的运作方式有不同的游戏变体。我家人通常玩的那种是，你有不管多少人，10个人，10件礼物。它们都是包好的。第一个人先上，挑一件礼物，把它打开。然后第二个人有选择权。
They can either pick a wrapped gift or they can take a gift that someone's already opened up if they like it. So you're not typically getting... That is a recipe for hurt feelings. Yeah, I mean, it's supposed to be fun. And typically you're supposed to put a dollar limit. So like you'd put like a $20 limit. Have you done it and ever had it be fun and not have hurt feelings? Oh yeah. It's always fun. It's like silly gifts. Like it's $20.
他们既可以选一件包好的礼物，也可以拿别人已经打开的礼物，如果他们喜欢的话。所以你通常不会拿到……这简直是引发怨恨的秘诀。对，我的意思是，这本该是好玩的。而且通常你应该设定一个金额上限。比如设定个20美元的上限。你玩过并且觉得好玩且没有引发怨恨吗？哦，当然。一直都挺好玩的。就像是些搞笑的小礼物。大概20美元。
No one's like it's $20. Like, um, we're not like it's, uh, I mean, typically my, I think the last time I did it, it was not last year cause last year I didn't go home for Christmas. Um, but two years ago I think I, um, it was, I had had a I think it was like aardvark hot sauce or like a hot sauce from that shows show hot hot ones on YouTube. And it's a very delicious hot sauce. And so I think my gift got stolen like, you know, two or three times. And so, you know, it's a little bit sad if your gift never gets stolen, because that means that like no one wanted your gift enough to want to steal it.
没人会觉得这20美元……我们不会，嗯，通常我的，我想我上次玩的时候，不是去年，因为去年我没回家过圣诞节。嗯，但两年前我想我，嗯，当时我，我有一瓶，我想大概是阿德瓦克辣酱，或者YouTube上那个《Hot Ones》节目里的某种辣酱。那是一款非常美味的辣酱。所以我想我的礼物大概被偷（换）走了两三次，所以，你知道的，如果你的礼物从来没有被人偷走，那就有点悲哀了，因为那意味着没有人想要你的话礼物到连偷它的欲望都没有。
That being said, like I don't, you know, it's, if someone really, really wanted something and they're like, look like they're bummed at the end of it, I'm pretty sure they'll just,
话虽如此，我并不，你知道的，如果有人真的非常想要某个东西，而且他们看起来，到最后觉得很沮丧，我相当确信他们会，
whatever, swap it with whoever. And, and yeah, there's usually some rules like you, a gift can only been, can be stolen like a maximum number of times. Otherwise, you can end up with like an infinite cycle.
管他呢，跟任何人换一下就行了。而且，是的，通常有一些规则，比如一件礼物只能被偷（换）走最高次数。否则，你可能会陷入无限循环。
This is so complicated. It's not complicated. It's not. How is it complicated? Your big brain can't handle either steal gift or open. Jews, we don't do this. Jews, we don't do this. We find other ways to make life complicated.
这太复杂了。一点都不复杂。才不呢。怎么就复杂了？你们的大脑连“偷礼物”还是“拆礼物”都处理不了吗？犹太人可不搞这个。犹太人可不搞这个。我们找别的方法把生活搞复杂。
This is not one of them. You find this. You literally work on one of the this you find this you literally work on one of the most complicated programming languages in the world which has like a 2000 plus page standard and you think that white elephant gift exchange is complicated um it one of these two things involves significantly more people and human interactions than the others. Although. I don't even actually know which one you're referring to.
这可不是其中之一。你觉得这个复杂。你明明在开发世界上最复杂的编程语言之一，它有2000多页的标准，而你却觉得白象礼物交换很复杂，嗯，这两件事中，有一件涉及更多的人和人际交往。虽然。我其实甚至不知道你指的是哪一个。
I assume you mean the ISO standard, but like. No, I actually meant the other way around. But then I realized, oh, wait, no. Like, yeah, most of my job is to be like a software politician these days. Oh, boy. All right. Now that we've spent, what is that, like 30 minutes answering your Christmas question? I don't even want to look at how many minutes we spent, but it was about 20 minutes because I got on at 6.33.
我假设你指的是 ISO 标准，但……不，我其实指的是反过来。但后来我意识到，哦，等等，不是。就像，是的，我大部分的工作就是当一个软件政治家。哦，天哪。好了。既然我们已经花了，大概多少，30分钟来回答你关于圣诞节的问题？我甚至不想看我们花了多少分钟，但大概有20分钟，因为我6点33分上线的。
We are going to share a window. So what did you get me for Christmas? I didn't get you. I did not get you anything. I got this cookie in the mail. It came in a box. I don't know who sent it to me. I did not send you a cookie, and I do not recommend eating the cookie of unknown origin.
我们要共享一个窗口。那你给我买什么圣诞礼物了？我没给你买。我什么都没给你买。我收到了一块饼干。是用信封寄来的。我不知道是谁寄给我的。我没有给你寄饼干，而且我不建议吃来源不明的饼干。
It should be fine. It's called a Neuenenberg or Neuerberg gingerbread cookie. Did somebody really? Wait, Connor, seriously. You don't know who sent you that cookie and you're eating it? Well, we're going to have to record for another 30 minutes just, like, so that I can go to sleep and not, like, worry that, like, you were poisoned and died. Okay.
应该没问题吧。这叫诺伊嫩贝格或诺伊尔贝格姜饼。真的有人吗？等等，康纳，说真的。你不知道是谁给你寄的饼干，然后你就吃了？好吧，我们得再录音30分钟，为了，就像，好让我能去睡觉，不用担心，比如说，你被毒死了然后死掉。好吧。
Yeah, I sucked my teeth into it, but uh bryce scared me so i didn't actually i didn't actually eat it back to um the next portion of this holiday special folks let's take a look at how we've been doing globally first of all all, we love you, Slovenia. But what happened? What happened, Slovenia? Oh, no. At one point, we, so, at one point, we got to eighth position
对，我咬了一口，但是，嗯，布莱斯把我吓坏了，所以我其实没有，我其实没有吃。回到，嗯，节日特别程序的下一部分，各位，让我们来看看我们全球的表现。首先，我们爱你，斯洛文尼亚。但是怎么回事？怎么回事，斯洛文尼亚？哦，不。曾经有一度，我们，所以，曾经有一度，我们冲到了第八位，
as the number eight technology podcast. Can we see that point on the graph? No, because it only shows you the last month unless if you pay
作为第八大科技播客。我们能在图表上看到那个时间点吗？不，因为除非你付钱给
this program, this website money. Well, how much money do I have to pay this website? Let's check. Chartable overview. You'd think they'd have a faster button to... To take our money, right? Yeah.
这个程序，这个网站，否则它只显示最近一个月。好吧，我得付给这个网站多少钱？我们查一下。Chartable 概览。你本以为他们会有一个更快按钮来……拿走我们的钱，对吧？对。
So look, Connor and I know absolutely nothing about web design and UI design. Like literally absolutely nothing about web design and UI design. Like, literally absolutely nothing. But all of you UI and web designers out there, pro tip, always put the button that lets us pay you money. Make it real big. Put it on every page. It's got to be, like, one click. Like, this has taken long enough that my desire to give you money
所以你看，康纳和我对网页设计和 UI 设计一无所知。字面意义上的对网页设计和 UI 设计一无所知。真的，一无所知。但是所有在座的 UI 和网页设计师们，专业提示，永远把那个让我们付钱给你的按钮放出来。做大一点。把它放在每个页面上。它必须是，比如说，只需点击一下。这花的时间太长了，以至于我想给你们钱的欲望
has gone down chartable it's crazy actually this is actually very shocking we literally could not find a way to give this this platform our money. All right, we should move on. We should literally move on because we've spent too much time on this.
都下降了，Chartable。这太疯狂了，其实这真的非常令人震惊，我们竟然真的找不到办法把钱送给这个平台。好吧，我们该继续了。我们真的该继续了，因为我们在上面花的时间太多了。
Charitable, we probably would have, you probably lost a customer today. You probably lost a customer. This is crazy. Yeah. It's, damn. But go back to the list. Go back to the list because I think I saw Kenya on there. Yeah, yeah.
Chartable，你们可能，你们今天可能失去了一个客户。你们可能失去了一个客户。这太疯狂了。对。太糟了。不过回到那个榜单上。回到那个榜单上，因为我好像看到上面有肯尼亚。对，对。
So, you know, it's Slovenia. We love you. At one point, we're contacted by some podcast stat thing. It actually wasn't Chartable. It was a different one, pod status or something. And they told us we were ranked 11th in Slovenia. At some point, that peaked to 8. Woo!
所以，你知道的，斯洛文尼亚。我们爱你。曾经有一度，我们被某个播客统计的数据联系了。其实不是 Chartable。是另一个，pod status 之类的。他们告诉我们在斯洛文尼亚排名第 11。在某个时候，那个排名达到了顶峰，第 8。呜呼！
But we haven't hit number one. So, yeah, Slovenia, let us know what we can do. I'm going to get us T-shirts printed saying that ADSP is one of the top 10 tech podcasts in Slovenia. Yeah, well, I think we can get to number one, honestly. And so I've... Yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay. And so there's a bunch of...
但我们还没冲到第一名。所以，是的，斯洛文尼亚，让我们知道我们能做些什么。我要去印一些 T 恤，上面写着 ADSP 是斯洛文尼亚十大科技播客之一。是的，好吧，说实话，我认为我们可以冲到第一名。所以我……对，对，对。好吧。所以有一堆……
I sort of perused through a bunch of different countries, and we're going to let you know if your country loves us. So Romania, we've got a pretty good track record in Romania. At one point, we were ranked number six not bad not bad wow i think greece we did pretty good yeah we got to number seven greece what i'm talking about uh let's check out kenya number seven as well pretty awesome currently ranked 37th. It's pretty cyclical. So the way it works is like we drop an episode on Friday and then Saturday we'll jump up and then typically it'll die down.
我大致浏览了一堆不同的国家，我们要让你们知道你的国家是否爱我们。所以罗马尼亚，我们在罗马尼亚有相当不错的记录。曾经有一度，我们排名第六，还不错，还不错，哇，我觉得希腊我们做得也挺好，对，我们排到了第七名，希腊，这就是我要说的，嗯，让我们看看肯尼亚，也是第七名，相当棒，目前排名第37位。这挺有规律的。它的运作方式就像是我们在周五发布一集，然后周六排名会跃升，通常之后就会回落。
Can you – and I think Ghana, we do really well in Ghana as well. Number four. I just had a really good chat dinner with this fellow that he's a tech recruiter, but he's worked in C++ for a long time, lives in New York. But he also, he lives in New York part-time, lives in Ghana part-time, and he's interested in creating a pipeline to get students from various African countries into tech internships. Yeah. And there's a lot of like there's a lot of unrealized potential for programmers in Africa. Yeah. Untapped talent. potential uh for for programmers in in africa yeah untapped talent yeah yeah like you like i don't i think like people don't like realize like how large some of these african countries are um like there's like 300 million people live in nigeria or something like that and it's it's becoming a big tech hub it's becoming a big tech hub i think uh i think i think africa is going to be the next what 300 million people live in nigeria yeah yeah i'm pretty sure that's right if not
你能——而且我觉得加纳，我们在加纳也做得非常好。第四名。我刚才跟这家伙吃晚饭聊得很开心，他是一个技术招聘人员，但他做 C++ 很久了，住在纽约。但他同时，他一部分时间住在纽约，一部分时间住在加纳，他有兴趣建立一个渠道，把来自各个非洲国家的学生送进科技实习岗位。对。而且有很多人，有许多未被发掘的非洲程序员的潜力。对。未被发掘的人才。潜力，嗯，针对非洲的程序员，是的，未被发掘的人才，是的，是的，就像你，就像我，我觉得人们没有意识到其中一些非洲国家有多大，嗯，就像有300万人住在尼日利亚或者类似的地方，它正在成为一个大型科技枢纽，它正在成为一个大型科技枢纽，我认同，我认同，我认同非洲将成为下一个，什么，300万人住在尼日利亚，是的，是的，我确信是这样的，如果不是的话，
wait uh let me don't tell me anything sorry i thought like 200 million 200 million sorry that's still that's still way up there a lot that's still that's got to be like what top 10 most populated countries because like u.s breaks the top five, I think, at 330 or whatever they're at right now. Nigeria ranks number seven in the list of countries by population. Yeah, that's crazy. I had no idea. Yeah. Let me think. I think like every tech company needs to have like a hiring operation and a,
等等，嗯，让我，别告诉我任何事，抱歉，我以为像200万，200万，抱歉，那依然，那依然很高，很多，那大概得排在前十人口最多的国家里，因为像美国跻身前五，我想，在3.3亿或者他们现在的那个数字。尼日利亚在全球国家人口排名中排第七。对，太疯狂了。我完全不知道。对。让我想想。我觉得每个科技公司都需要有一个招聘运营，
and a pipeline with colleges in, in Africa. Yeah, that's a, I had no idea. I can probably rattle off the top five populous countries, but if you ask me to do six to 10, I wouldn't suggest Nigeria.
以及一个与非洲高校对接的渠道。对，这个，我完全不知道。我大概能顺口说出人口最多的前五名国家，但如果你让我说出6到10名，我不会猜到尼日利亚。
All right, go. I got it right here. Go. Am I going to get this right in order? So I know China and India are one and two, I think, in that order. China, India are one and two, correct? Oh, here we go um is indonesia number three indonesia is in the top five but it's not number four it is number four who's number three uh then i'm gonna go with the u.s that is correct the u.s number three who is number five number five i will edit out this silence while i while i try and think
好吧，来吧。我就在这里。来吧。我能按顺序猜对吗？所以中国和印度是一和二，我想，就是那个顺序。中国、印度是一和二，对吧？哦，我们来咯，嗯，印度尼西亚是第三吗？印度尼西亚在前五名里，但它不是第四，它是第四，那是谁第三，嗯，那我猜美国，回答正确，美国第三，那谁是第五，第五，我会把这段沉默剪掉，当我，当我努力思考的时候，
mexico no mexico's number 10 you're you're off by 100 million well let's see if I can keep going and see if I can get five, six, eight, and nine. Yeah. Yeah. So, you know, Nigeria is seven. Yeah. Australia? What? Are you kidding?
墨西哥？不，墨西哥是第十，你猜差了1亿。好吧，让我们看看我能不能继续猜，看能不能猜出五、六、八和九。对。对。所以，你知道的，尼日利亚是第七。对。澳大利亚？什么？你在开玩笑吧？
That was not my guess. Australia is 55. There are like 25 million people in Australia. Brazil? Yeah. But like, why did you say Australia? Can we go back to that? Yeah, Brazil's number six.
那可不是我的猜测。澳大利亚是 55 名。澳大利亚大概只有 2500 万人。巴西？对。但是，为什么你会说澳大利亚？我们能回到那个话题吗？对，巴西是第六名。
Should I cut out me guessing Australia? No, you are not allowed to cut out you guessing Australia. Oh, no, you're definitely not allowed to cut that out. And did you, you said Russia, I think? I did not. Russia? Yeah, yeah. I thought you said Russia, but yeah, you said Russia, I think? I did not. Russia? Yeah. Yeah.
我应该把我猜澳大利亚的那段剪掉吗？不，你绝对不准把我猜澳大利亚的那段剪掉。哦，不，你绝对不准把它剪掉。而且你，你刚才说俄罗斯，对吧？我没说。俄罗斯？对，对。我以为你说了俄罗斯，不过，对，你刚才说俄罗斯，对吧？我没说。俄罗斯？对。对。
I thought you said Russia, but yeah, you get Russia. Mexico was 10. You're missing five is Pakistan and six is Bangladesh. But here's another interesting thing. Out of those top 10, guess which one is the fastest growing? Nigeria? Correct. And Ethiopia is 12 at 114 million and also is growing pretty fast.
我以为你说了俄罗斯，不过，对，你猜对了俄罗斯。墨西哥是第十。你漏掉了第五是巴基斯坦，第六是。但这里还有一件有趣的事。在那些前十名中，你猜哪个增长最快？尼日利亚？正确。埃塞俄比亚排在第十二位，有 1.14 亿人口，而且增长也相当快。
All right. So, yeah. All right. What other countries do people listen to us in? I think all of the sort of countries near like czech czechia you're gonna you're gonna have to edit that out because i'm not sure in what way you are being politically offensive um well well you you could have you could have said i think you can say the balkans yeah i think balkans is fine You could have said the Balkans.
好了。所以，对。好吧。还有什么国家的人在听我们播客？我觉得所有那些靠近捷克、捷克利亚的国家，你得，你得把它剪掉，因为我不确定你在以何种方式在政治上具有冒犯性，嗯，好吧，你本可以，你本可以这么说，我觉得你可以说巴尔干地区，是的，我觉得巴尔干地区没问题，你可以说巴尔干地区。
But now you're talking about the Baltics, which is the Latvia, Estonia. So how are we doing in Latvia? Wow, we were number three in Latvia. Estonia, number seven. Number seven. Not feeling the love as much as Latvia. Mongolia. Mongolia.
但现在你谈论的是波罗的海地区，也就是拉脱维亚、爱沙尼亚。我们在拉脱维亚表现怎么样？哇，我们在拉脱维亚排名第三。爱沙尼亚，第七名。第七名。没有像拉脱维亚那样感受到爱意。蒙古。蒙古。
Actually, I didn't know what have we armenia i'd love to be uh number 14 at one point in armenia so i haven't clicked on the country that we at least as far as i can tell peaked the highest at so we got to number two in a country can you guess that country um here let's open i'll open the google maps no i don't need a google map i don't need a google map poland did me opening up the google map and then poland being no no that that's it that's it that's it nothing i was just thinking where are where do i know that there are good like c++ programmers and i know that that in particular there are there's a lot of good c++ programmers come out of poland there's a lot of good universities there that teach systems programming and so i thought
其实，我不知道，亚美尼亚，我希望在亚美尼亚曾经达到过第 14 名，所以我还没有点开那个我们至少据我所知达到最高峰值的国家，我们在一个国家排到了第二名，你能猜到那个国家吗？嗯，来吧，我们打开，我打开谷歌地图，不，我不需要谷歌地图，我不需要谷歌地图，波兰，难道是因为我打开谷歌地图，然后波兰被，不，不，那就是，那就是，没有什么，我只是在想，哪里有我所知道的优秀的 C++ 程序员，我知道波兰有很多优秀的 C++ 程序员，那里有很多优秀的大学教授系统编程，所以我想
perhaps we'd have a particular audience there and it's a country with a larger population no i was wrong all right fine i can be wrong what what which country which country then well here so i'll i'll i'll rotate and i'll zoom in and so we're looking at basically europe portugal and spain are in the bottom left ukraine and belarus are in the top right country it's on this map. It's on this map. And every guess, I'll zoom in a couple clicks. It's the game we'll play here. And listener, root for yourself because your country could get called. Hungary? It is not Hungary.
也许我们在那里有特定的听众，而且它是一个人口较多的国家，不，我猜错了，好吧，没关系，我也会猜错，究竟是哪个国家，究竟是哪个国家呢？好吧，那我，我旋转一下，然后放大，所以我们基本上在看欧洲，葡萄牙和西班牙在左下角，乌克兰和白俄罗斯在右上角，国家，它就在这张地图上。它就在这张地图上。而且你每猜一次，我就放大几击。这是我们在这儿玩的游戏。而且听众，为你们自己加油吧，因为你们的国家可能会被点到。匈牙利？不是匈牙利。
I will zoom in. It's somewhere in the Balkans. I know it's somewhere in the Balkans. I know it's somewhere in the Balkans. Four. I guess I got to go with Serbia. It is not Serbia, but I will zoom in. One, two. That's as far as I'll go.
我会放大。它在巴尔干地区的某个地方。我知道它在巴尔干地区的某个地方。我知道它在巴尔干地区的某个地方。4。我猜我得选塞尔维亚。不是塞尔维亚，但我会放大。1，2。我就放大到这儿。
So Bryce is very close, because there's only how many countries we've got? Italy, Austria, Slovakia, Slovenia, Croatia. I'm sorry, but I got to rule Italy out. I know it's one of these, you know, it's not Italy. I'm almost certain it's not Italy. Or Bulgaria. And Romania is on the screen.
所以布莱斯非常接近，因为我们有几个国家？意大利、奥地利、斯洛伐克、斯洛文尼亚、克罗地亚。抱歉，但我得把意大利排除。我知道是其中之一，你知道的，不是意大利。我几乎可以肯定是意大利。或者保加利亚。罗马尼亚就在屏幕上。
But so we know, we've seen Slovenia, we've seen Romania, and Bryce's guessed Hungary and Serbia. I don't think it could be Kosovo or Montenegro. So I guess I'm going to have to go with Croatia. It is Croatia. Let's take a look at Croatia. Oh, that's so exciting. I mean, I think it's safe to say that if we are ever the number one technology podcast in your country, we will come to your country and, like, give some tech talks and record an episode there.
但所以我们知道，我们见过斯洛文尼亚，我们见过罗马尼亚，布莱斯猜了匈牙利和塞尔维亚。我觉得不可能是科索沃或黑山。所以我猜我只能选克罗地亚了。是克罗地亚。我们来看看克罗地亚。哦，太令人兴奋了。我的意思是，我觉得可以肯定地说，如果我们有朝一日成为你们国家排名第一的科技播客，我们会去你们的国家，举办一些技术讲座并在那里录制一集节目。
I thought I actually had that idea. Hang on, hang on, hang on. This offer does not apply to like North Korea or any other countries that I legally cannot go to. I was thinking that, I mean, I really would love to be number one in Slovenia because, you know, they're a part of our podcast lore now too. And how funny would it be for you and i if like in the future there was an iso c++ meeting like in that neck of the woods uh that we just hopped over to slovenia and recorded like a a vlog of you and me yeah yeah i mean i hear it's a lovely country yeah i mean the capital do you want to take a stab at pronouncing that? Oh, no. No, I very much do not want to take a stab at pronouncing that.
我当时其实有这个想法。等等，等等，等等。这个提议不适用于朝鲜或任何其他我法律上不能去的国家。我在想，真的，我非常想在斯洛文尼亚排第一，因为，你知道的，他们现在也是我们播客传说的一部分了。对你我来说，如果未来有一次 ISO C++ 会议正好在那个地区举办，我们顺便跳到斯洛文尼亚，录制一个你我的 Vlog 会有多搞笑，是的，是的，我的意思是，我听说那是个可爱的国家，是的，我的意思是，首都是，你想试着发音那个词吗？哦，不。不，我非常不想试着发音那个词。
I would like you to take a stab at pronouncing that. I'm going to guess that the L's are silent, and it's just Jubjana. But there's an L before each of the J's. It's L-J-U-B, L-J-A-N-A. What we can do is open up a, how'd you say, how to pronounce? Wow. It was Ljubljana. Okay. Not Jjabjana. So you you were you were quite wrong i was it was quite quite wrong yeah well if like if there was like a committee meeting in italy then we could just pop on over to slovenia we could probably we could pop on over to slovenia and then stop in croatia on our way yeah we should do what so what is is the oh my god we should do we should do what? So what is, is the, oh my God, we should do, we should do an ADSP Balkans road trip.
我希望你试着发音那个词。我猜 L 是不发音的，大概是 Jubjana。但在每个 J 前面都有一个 L。它是 L-J-U-B, L-J-A-N-A。我们能做的是打开一个，怎么说，如何发音？哇。是 Ljubljana。好吧。不是 Jjabjana。所以你，你，错得相当离谱，我是，错得相当离谱，是的，如果，如果在意大利有一场委员会会议，那么我们就可以顺便去斯洛文尼亚，我们大概可以顺便去斯洛文尼亚，然后在路上在克罗地亚停留，是的，我们应该做，所以什么是，哦，天哪，我们应该做，我们应该做什么？所以什么是，是，哦，天哪，我们应该做，我们应该进行一次 ADSP 巴尔干公路旅行。
That is clearly what we have to do. Yep. Is, uh, is it politically correct? So like, I guess we got to keep all this in now. The Balkans. I'm pretty sure that there's like the term Balkanizedized that's not a good like don't use that anymore and that has negative connotations i know that that's on our list of terms with negative connotations and uh for for insights but the balkans is just the name of the region and i
这显然是我们必须要做的事情。没错。是，嗯，这在政治上正确吗？所以，我想我们现在得把这些都保留下来。巴尔干地区。我相当确信有个词叫“巴尔干化”，那个词不太好，像，别再用那个了，带有负面含义，我知道那是我们负面含义术语黑名单上的，嗯，针对见解而言，但巴尔干只是该地区的名称，我
i do not think that it is a politically loaded term for the name of the region. I think, yeah, I think it's totally fine. Google seems to be saying that that is correct. Yeah. If it's not, if you are from one of these Balkan countries and this is offensive, please let us know ASAP. Yeah. I would have to say for Americans and Canadians, my guess would be that the part of European geography that we know the least about is the Balkan Peninsula. If you sat down your average American in front of a map, they'd probably do a better job at guessing where
不认为这个名称具有政治敏感性。我觉得，是的，我觉得完全没问题。谷歌似乎也认为这是对的。是的。如果不是的话，如果你来自这些巴尔干国家之一并且这被认为具有冒犯性，请尽快让我们知道。是的。我得说，对于美国人和加拿大人来说，我猜我们对欧洲地理了解最少的部分就是巴尔干半岛。如果你让一个普通的美国人坐在地图前，他们猜
France, Germany, Austria, the Czech Republic, Slovakia are than any of the, and like, like where Italy is than any of the countries in, uh, in the Balkan peninsula. That'd be my guess. Oh, so Slovakia doesn't make the cut for the Balkans. But I like it. The Balkan ADSP tour 2022, 2023? Obviously, if we're going to do an ADSP Balkans road trip, we will have to go up to Bruno and visit Hana on our way out of Europe. So we will have to, you know, we could like drive down the coast and then like go up through, I don't know.
法国、德国、奥地利、捷克共和国、斯洛伐克的位置，大概会比猜巴尔干半岛任何国家的位置做得更好，包括意大利在哪儿。这就是我的猜测。哦，所以斯洛文尼亚不入选巴尔干地区。但我喜欢这个。巴尔干 ADSP 巡演 2022，2023？显然，如果我们要做一次 ADSP 巴尔干公路旅行，我们在离开欧洲的路上必须去布尔诺拜访哈娜。所以我们必须，你知道的，我们可以开车沿着海岸南下，然后，嗯，从上面北上，我不知道。
Oh, yeah, it's just a hop and a skip away. I mean, like, look, Europe's not that large. Like this is a big, Modulo, like any border issues that I don't know about, like this is a pretty viable road trip. You know what would be cool, Connor? It would be cool to see on a map the distribution of where people listen to the podcast. Do we have anything like that?
哦，是的，那只是跳一下就到的距离。我的意思是，看，欧洲没那么大。就像这是一个，取模，抛开我不知道的任何边境问题，这绝对是一次可行的公路旅行。你知道什么会很酷吗，康纳？在地图上看到人们收听播客的地理分布情况会很酷。我们有类似的东西吗？
Yeah, I can take you to – actually, actually i don't know let's go to stats i don't think it shows us that it shows us our most listened to episodes popular apps but it doesn't say geography on buzzsprout which is our hoster hosting platform i guess it's good that i know that in case you get hit by a bus. I do have some bad news listeners, which is Connor does all the editing for this. I'm just the executive producer. I don't actually know how any of this works. And what that means is that if Connor got hit by a bus, this would be over. I would not even be able to upload the episode telling you that Connor was hit by the bus. Yeah, maybe I should. should i mean that's a little i don't want yeah
对，我可以带你去——其实，其实我不知道，我们去看看统计数据吧，我觉得上面不会显示这个，它会显示我们收听最多的单集和热门应用，但不会显示地理位置，在 Buzzsprout 上没有，这是我们的托管平台。我想，如果哪天你被公共汽车撞了，我能知道这些挺好的。听众朋友们，我有个坏消息，那就是康纳负责这档节目的所有剪辑。我只是执行制片人。其实我根本不知道这玩意儿怎么运作。这意味着如果康纳被公共汽车撞了，这一切就结束了。我甚至没办法上传一集节目来告诉大家康纳被公交车撞了。对，也许我应该……我是说，这有点……我不想……对。
i was gonna say i could i could upload you an episode like while i'd still be alive being like the podcast is over because i died uh you all you would have to do is i could i could give you you know i'd write down on some you know piece of paper or whatever email and that you could log in and just hit the publish button. This is episode, you know, X, Y, Z. Unfortunately, I did get hit by a bus. I mean, I think we should do it. I think we should do it. I feel like that's the I don't know.
我本想说，我可以在我还活着的时候给你上传一集，就说播客结束了，因为我死了。呃，你唯一需要做的就是……我可以把账号密码写在什么纸上，或者是发邮件，然后你可以登录并直接点击发布按钮。这是第……呃，X，Y，Z 集。不幸的是，我确实被公共汽车撞了。我是说，我觉得我们应该这么做。我觉得我们应该这么做。我感觉那是……我不知道。
It's not like superstition or karma or whatever, but like, I feel like that's like you're setting yourself to get hit by a bus. So speaking of superstition, my, as I've mentioned a few times in this episode, my family is Jewish. My mother's side are all Russian Jews. And I can't tell if it's my family in particular or just the culture in general, but my people are pretty superstitious. My great-great-grandmother, whose name was Sora, refused to teach my great-grandmother how to cook or bake. The reason for this was that if she taught my great-grandmother to do these things, that she would then become redundant, and that would be like, you know, would bring about her doom. It wasn't that like she was like afraid that like somebody was going to kill her.
这倒不是迷信、因果报应之类的事情，但我觉得，这就好像你在预示自己会被公交车撞一样。所以说到迷信，正如我在这一集里提到过好几次的，我的家庭是犹太人。我母亲那边全都是俄国犹太人。我分不清这是我家族的特质还是普遍文化如此，但我身边的人相当迷信。我的曾祖母，名字叫索拉，拒绝教我的曾祖母如何做饭或烘焙。原因在于，如果她教我的曾祖母做这些事情，她自己就会变得多余，这就好比会带来她的厄运。倒不是说她害怕有人会杀她。
Like, you know, if she, it's just like, she thought it was like, you know, it was bad luck to pass down these skills. And so when I heard this, I'm like, this doesn't make any sense. Like you're supposed to pass, there's supposed to be a transfer of knowledge from parent to child but uh apparently there are some things there are some things that we're supposed to take to the grave just uh you don't want to you don't want to invoke any bad luck that's a pretty crazy story yeah there's no superstition in my family at least i don't think uh all right well we got we've got 14 minutes left on this holiday special that was basically the only thing i had prepared was to tell slovenia that we love them and uh let us
就像，如果她……这只是，她认为这就像……把这些技能传下去会带来厄运。所以当我听到这个的时候，我觉得这根本说不通。就像你应该把……本该有一种从父母到孩子的知识传递，但呃，显然有些事情，有些事情我们是应该带进坟墓的，只是呃，你不想……你不想招惹任何霉运。这真是一个相当疯狂的故事。是的，我的家族里可没有什么迷信，至少我觉得没有。好吧，我们这个节日特辑还剩下14分钟，我准备好的唯一一件事就是告诉斯洛文尼亚我们爱他们，并且呃，让我们
know what we need to do to get to number one and i guess are we doing this balkan tour 2022 2023 2023 i will be in italy september 2023. Why do you know that? You got a wedding? No, it's my stepdad's 70th birthday. And so he wants to take us all to like a villa in Italy. So I just got to save the date today. And I was like, I better put that on my calendar. Because my calendar does tend to get filled up with things.
知道我们需要做些什么才能冲到第一名，然后我想……我们是要搞什么 2022、2023 巴尔干半岛之旅吗？2023 年我将在 2023 年 9 月去意大利。你怎么知道的？你要参加婚礼吗？不，那是我继父的 70 岁生日。所以他想带我们全家去意大利的一个别墅。所以我今天刚刚把日期定下来。当时我想，我最好把它记在我的日历上。因为我的日程确实往往会被各种事情塞满。
So if you are if you are organizing a c++ conference or event and you would like me there please do not plan it uh for september 2nd to september 9th 2023 unless it is an event that is like right before or right after and happens to be in italy in which case I'll definitely show up. Oh, that would be so awesome on our Balkan tour. It would be so awesome if C++ conferences were scheduled around my family holidays. Yes, I agree. I agree, especially if your conference will pay for my plane ticket. No, my brain went five steps you said wedding no conferences unless
所以，如果你正在组织一个 C++ 会议或活动，并且希望我在场，请千万不要把它安排在 2023 年 9 月 2 日到 9 月 9 日之间，除非这是一个恰好在意大利举行，并且就在那之前或那之后的活动，如果是那样的话，我一定会出席。哦，那我们的巴尔干之旅可就太棒了。如果 C++ 会议能围绕着我的家庭假期来安排，那就太棒了。是的，我同意。我同意，特别是如果你的会议能帮我报销机票的话。不，我的脑回路已经跳了五步了。你说了婚礼，然后我就想到了会议，除非
before after then i started thinking about conferences slash meetups and then i went to thinking like oh wouldn't it be awesome if we if we act well i don't know how long is our balkan tour because hypothetically if we could go for like a month and record a live episode like in every major city that we went to although what are the odds like you know how many people do you think are actually is it like you know like 10 people 50 people 100 people in each like capital of these countries or is it just we're getting lucky in this algorithm who knows who knows but i will i will say this i will say this i do think there is an interesting thing that that we could potentially do if we do ever go on some inventory of europe which is i would like to hear sort of
在前后，然后我开始考虑会议/聚会，然后我就开始想，哦，如果我们能够……呃，我不知道我们的巴尔干之旅有多长，因为假设我们能去一个月左右，并在我们去过的每个主要城市录制一期现场播客，那该有多棒啊。虽然这概率有多大呢？你知道，你觉得实际会有多少人？就像是……比如每个国家的首都只有 10 个人、50 个人、100 个人，还是说我们只是在这个算法里碰运气？谁知道呢，谁知道呢？但我得说，我得说，如果我们的确去欧洲进行什么巡回演出的话，我觉得有一件有趣的事我们可能会做，那就是我想听听
accounts from from from people in europe about who are C++ programmers. Why was this just specific to C++? Because this is what I'm interested in. I'd like to hear from C++ programmers in various parts of Europe how they became C++ programmers. Because we've talked a bit on this podcast about you and I's experience with the educational systems in, you know, America and Canada.
欧洲各地的人们关于……他们作为 C++ 程序员的故事。为什么这偏偏只针对 C++？因为这是我感兴趣的。我想听听欧洲各地的 C++ 程序员是如何成为 C++ 程序员的。因为我们在这个播客里稍微聊过你和我对美国和加拿大的教育系统的体验。
But, you know, I'd sort of be interested in hearing what it's like in other parts of the world and hearing how people came to become programmers in other parts of the world especially because i there is this phenomenon um uh where there's a lot of c++ programmers from uh uh eastern and central europe and i'd like to i'd like to learn more about you know how that happens like why are why are you all programming in C++? Is it just a different structure in the university system? Which is what my guess is, that you're taught different courses. There's just a different set of things that are prioritized in school. And that's what leads to the predominance of C++ in these countries. Let me ask you this.
但是，呃，我其实挺有兴趣听听世界其他地方是什么样的，听听世界其他地方的人是如何成为程序员的，尤其是因为我有一个现象，呃，有大量来自东欧和中欧的 C++ 程序员，我想，我想更多地了解那是怎么发生的，比如为什么你们所有人都在用 C++ 编程？这只是大学系统里不同的结构吗？我猜是这样的，就是你们学的课程不同。学校里优先考虑的东西有一套不同的组合。而这正是 C++ 在这些国家占据主导地位的原因。让我问你这个。
Were you at all surprised to hear that most of our viewership in Europe is in Central and Eastern Europe? I was not surprised by any locations really except for maybe some of the african countries now that's yeah that's i could see i could i could see how you'd be surprised with that because you have not like i just like have happened to have like had the same aha moment like one or two years ago where like I learned like, oh, hey, there's like a lot of there's a lot of young programmers in Africa right now. And in a few years, like that's going to be a big thing.
听到我们在欧洲的大部分收视/收听群体在中欧和东欧时，你感到惊讶吗？对于任何地点我其实都没有感到惊讶，可能除了某些非洲国家。现在，那是……对，我能理解，我能理解你为什么会对此感到惊讶，因为你没有像我一样……恰好在刚好一两年前有过同样的“啊哈”时刻，当时我了解到，哦，嘿，非洲现在有很多年轻程序员。几年后，那将会是一件大事。
Yeah, I guess like Ghana. I mean, if you had asked me to like, oh, where do you think you're most popular? There's no way I would have guessed Ghana. Um, only because like that, that's a country that's like peripherally on my radar, mostly because of like the world cup. Like if you asked me to like list some facts about Ghana, I wouldn't be able to say much. Um,
是的，我想就像加纳。我是说，如果你让我说，“哦，你觉得你们在哪个地方最受欢迎？”我绝不可能猜到加纳。呃，仅仅因为……那个国家只是在我的雷达边缘，主要是因为世界杯。如果你让我列举一些关于加纳的事实，我也说不出太多，呃，
the thing that I was most surprised about is that in several countries, like we had broken into the top 10, however they measure that, like, is it accurate? Is it not accurate um but uh yeah i do know that there is you know in in europe in certain countries there does seem to be uh higher than above an above average percentage of c++ developers when you compare it to you know other countries that we're more familiar with now all right my guess would be that that it's probably a difference in like the math education at um like younger years in education in education like like the middle school high school level i don't know whether middle school and high school or a thing in countries that aren't the u.s but that's my best guess yeah
让我最惊讶的是，在几个国家里，我们竟然挤进了前 10 名，不管他们是怎么统计的。这准确吗？不准确吗？但呃，是的，我确实知道，在欧洲的某些国家，确实似乎有……高于平均比例的 C++ 开发者，如果你拿它跟我们更熟悉的那些国家相比的话。好吧，我猜这可能是在教育的较早阶段……比如初中、高中水平的数学教育上存在差异。我不知道在非美国的国家里有没有初中和高中这种说法，但这是我最好的猜测。
it'd be interesting to know we will make it a point of whenever the balkan 2023 or 2022 we don't know yet um tour takes place we will we will definitely we'll have to figure out some kind of like mic situation where we can just bop around and we can go into interviewer mode regardless of whether it's a C++ or anything. We'll just be walking down the street and if someone says something to us, we'll whip out the mic and be like, we're here live with ADSP on the road, Balkan 2023. So I'm pretty sure there's this whole industry called podcasting that's figured out, you know, how to record people when you're running about. Like there are these people who are like podcasters, like do this like full time. Like I'm pretty sure, I'm pretty sure that's the solve problem. Pretty sure that's the solve problem. Yeah. We just get a mic, get a mic.
了解这些会很有趣，无论巴尔干 2023 还是 2022（我们还不知道）巡演在什么时候举行，我们都会把它作为一个重点，我们肯定得弄清楚某种麦克风情况，这样我们就可以到处闲逛，随时进入采访模式，不管是不是关于 C++ 或其他任何事情。我们会在街上走着，如果有人对我们说了什么，我们就会掏出麦克风说：“我们正在路上进行现场直播，与 ADSP 一同开启 2023 巴尔干之旅。”所以，我很确定有一个叫播客的整个行业，已经弄清楚了当你到处跑时如何录制人们的声音。就像有这样一群人，他们是播客，全职做这个。我很确定，我很确定这是一个已经解决的问题。我很确定这是一个已经解决的问题。是的。我们只要弄个麦克风，弄个麦克风。
That's all you need. All right. How do we want, how do we want to wrap up this holiday special so happy holidays i feel like last year last year's holiday special was way better um we mostly talked about globally where people were listening we got into an argument about blenders. We talked about whether Christmas is fun. The highlight was probably me pronouncing Ljubljana as Jubjana. There is
这就够了。好吧。我们想怎么……我们想怎么结束这个节日特辑呢？祝大家节日快乐！我觉得去年的节日特辑要好得多……我们主要讨论了人们在全球的收听地点，我们还为搅拌机争论了一番。我们讨论了圣诞节是否有意思。亮点可能是我把卢布尔雅那（Ljubljana）读成了祖布贾纳（Jubjana）。有
some chance that we offended a large chunk of Europe. No, we love you, Europe. Most of you. We do love you, Europe. Do we love all of Europe? Of course we love all of Europe.
一定几率我们冒犯了欧洲很大一部分人。不，我们爱你们，欧洲。大多数人。我们确实爱你们，欧洲。我们爱整个欧洲吗？当然，我们爱整个欧洲。
What part of Europe would we not love? Of course we love all of Europe. I don't know. I can't think of all the countries off the top of my head, but there's got to be a few. All right. Now I want you to name the parts of Europe that you do not love. I'm just saying i just don't want to say we love all of europe and find out that there's some country that's committing like you know war crimes or something and oh they said they love this and wow we got to backtrack three episodes later because we're getting canceled um well just
欧洲的哪个部分我们会不爱？当然我们爱整个欧洲。我不知道。我没法一下子说出所有的国家，但总得有几个吧。好吧。现在我要你点出那些你不太喜欢的欧洲部分。我只是说……我只是不想说我们爱整个欧洲，结果发现某个国家正在犯下……你知道的，战争罪之类的，然后，哦，他们说他们爱这个，哇，三集之后我们得撤回前言，因为我们要被取消关注/封杀了……好吧，只是
because you say you love a country doesn't mean that you current that you love the country's government right like that's a big difference. All right. Yeah, we love you, all of Europe and all of Africa. Yeah. Let's see. Do we become number one first in Ghana or Kenya? Or is it going to be, oh, yeah, we could go to Kenya too. I would really love to see a C++ conference in Africa.
因为你说你爱一个国家，并不意味着你当前……你爱这个国家的政府，对吧？这是一个很大的区别。好吧。是的，我们爱你们，全欧洲和全非洲。好吧。让我们看看。我们会先在加纳还是肯尼亚排名第一？或者会是……哦，对了，我们也可以去肯尼亚。我真的很想在非洲看到一个 C++ 会议。
Or let me put it this way. I'd really love to see a tech conference anywhere in Africa where I could go and talk about C++. Yeah. Yeah, and I would love to go to Kenya as well because I could basically train there at altitude for a week or however long I was there, come back, run some like half marathon or marathon, and I would clearly set a personal best because... My first choice would probably be Nigeria, and that's just because I know the largest number
或者换个方式说。我真的很想在非洲的任何地方看到一个技术会议，我可以去那里聊聊 C++。对。是的，我也很想去肯尼亚，因为我基本上可以在那里进行为期一周（或无论待多久）的高原训练，然后回来，跑个半马或全马，我绝对能创造个人最好成绩，因为……我的第一选择可能是尼日利亚，这只是因为我知道在尼日利亚有最多
of C++ people in Nigeria. But I'll take anything. Anywhere is good for me. All right, the call. We've set up a lot of stuff for the future. We've got the Balkans. I guess we have to do like an Africa tour too. Yeah.
的 C++ 从业者。但我什么都接受。对我来说去哪儿都行。好吧，号召。我们为未来做了很多规划。我们要去巴尔干半岛。我想我们也得搞个非洲巡演。是的。
Although I feel like we've got to wait until we've got a couple more countries where we break into the top 10. And Kenya and Nigeria are on opposite sides of the continent um yeah and i'm not so sure that i'm not so sure that the road trip works in uh in africa i do not i do not yeah there are some countries between kenya and nigeria that i do not think two white guys can do. Bryce, Bryce, we've already offended enough of the Balkan countries. Let's quit while we're behind.
虽然我觉得我们得等到我们在更多的国家挤进前 10 名才行。而且肯尼亚和尼日利亚在大陆的两端，呃，是的，而且我不太确定……我不太确定自驾游在非洲行得通。我真的……我真的不觉得行得通。在肯尼亚和尼日利亚之间有一些国家，我不认为两个白人小伙子能搞定。布莱斯，布莱斯，我们已经得罪够多巴尔干国家了。我们还是在落后的时候收手吧。
I actually think it's more likely that we'd offend, that we'd cause offense to folks in the European countries than to folks in Africa., than to folks in, uh, in Africa. All right. Well, there you have it. We're doing, uh, so much trouble for this episode,
我其实觉得，我们更有可能冒犯到……我们在欧洲国家的人群中引起冒犯的几率，要大于在非洲……在非洲人群中引起冒犯的几率。好吧。好了，情况就是这样。我们在这集节目里惹上了……好大的麻烦，
Africa, 2024. Yes. Balkans, 2023, maybe 2022. If, uh,
非洲，2024。是的。巴尔干半岛，2023，也许是 2022。如果，呃，
you know, Omicron and I, I, I have a feeling that, that are like three week road trip through the balkans is going to take a little bit more planning than than than that but we can do it maybe yeah all right with that we'll say happy holidays if you celebrate christmas merry christmas happy holidays even if you don't celebrate christmas yeah have have hopefully you're taking some time off,
你知道，奥密克戎……而且我有一种感觉，我们在巴尔干半岛为期三周的自驾游需要的规划要比那……比那要多得多，但我们可以做到，也许吧。好吧，那就这样，我们祝大家节日快乐，如果你庆祝圣诞节，圣诞快乐，节日快乐，即使你不庆祝圣诞节。是的，有……希望你能抽出一些时间放松一下，
spending time with friends and family and stay safe. Stay safe. Canada's going back, or at least Toronto's going back into lockdown. Will Connor get to go to the Nutcracker ballet? My tickets might get canceled. Stay tuned. Pretty sure.
花时间和朋友家人在一起，并注意安全。注意安全。加拿大又要封城了，或者说至少多伦多又要封城了。康纳还能去看《胡桃夹子》芭蕾舞剧吗？我的票可能会被取消。请持续关注。我很确定。
After the knee ballet. I'm pretty hopeful. I'd really like to see the Bears on rollerblades. All right. With that, I'm going to stop recording. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在膝盖芭蕾舞之后。我挺抱歉的/我很抱歉……我挺抱歉的，我真的很想看穿着轮滑鞋的熊。好吧。就这样，我要停止录音了。感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝大家有个美好的一天。这集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。